SUSAN JANE GILMAN: Hi.
I'm Susan Jane Gilman.
Thank you for coming to "The Ice
Cream Queen of Orchard Street."
I'm going to speak today a
bit about the creative process
because "The Ice Cream
Queen of Orchard Street"
is my fourth book, but
it's my first novel.
I always intended
to be a novelist,
but it took me about
30 years to get here.
My first books were
nonfiction, and they came out
of a very different
place than "The Ice Cream
Queen" I've wanted to
be a novelist since I
was eight years old.
I used to buy little
notebooks at the dime store
and divide them in half
and write the story on top
and illustrate
them on the bottom.
And I wrote my first
novel at age nine.
It was called "Bunny House."
It was about Bobby
and Bonnie Bunny
and how they wanted to
convince their mother
to buy them chocolate
covered carrots.
And I was so sure
the way you can
when you are only nine years
old that the world might believe
there were these
anthropomorphized rabbits
running around that I wrote
at the beginning of the book,
"This is fiction.
I made this up.
None of it is real."
I find myself now into my fourth
book having to tell people,
"This is fiction.
I made this up.
It's not real."
It's an immigrant story
and historic story,
and people have tended
to think of it as fact.
I've been getting angry emails.
That this woman does
not exist, that they
have googled Dunkle's
Ice Cream and they
can't find it anywhere.
I am a liar.
So I want to go
back a little bit
and tell you how this came
about, because ironically
my other books were nonfiction.
I always assumed that
I would write stories,
that I would make up stories the
way I loved to do as a child.
But as I grew up
and became a writer,
I kept getting distracted
by things in our culture.
I set out to write
the Great American
Novel-- or the mediocre
American novel.
I would just be
happy with a novel--
when I broke up with a
young man I was living with
and did not want to marry.
And somebody sent
me a book called
"The Rules: Time-Tested Tips
for Capturing the Heart of Mr.
Right."
And the rules essentially
urge young women
to act like diet soda.
Be artificially sweet and bubbly
for the rest of your life,
and you can trick a
man into marrying you.
And I said to some
friends of mine,
there out to be a book about
catching a life, not a husband.
Something that helps us
deal with all the messages
we get as women, such
as the fact that people
say that our bodies are more
important than our brains.
How do you deal
with relatives who
are putting pressure
on you to get married?
How do you treat your friends?
How do you gain political
power, negotiate a salary,
all the things that
are important to us
as young women that
will empower us.
But it has to be
funny, and it has
to be short because we're busy.
And they looked at me and they
said, well, you're the writer.
You go ahead and write it.
And I'd been working on a
precious book of short stories.
I'd been working on the novel.
But this was the book that sort
of resonated with publishers.
And before I knew it,
I had a best seller.
It was called
"Kiss My Tiara: How
to Rule the World as
a SmartMouth Goddess."
So then, OK, I sat down.
I'm going to write the novel,
and September 11 happened.
I'm a native New Yorker.
My whole family was here except
my husband and I at that time
were in Washington, DC.
And it was a very bad day.
And afterwards, the only
thing I wanted to read
were true stories but funny
stories, light stories,
something that kept me
from having to take Xanax
and that gave me
hope in humanity.
And yet when I read the books
that young women were writing,
all these memoirs were about
being single or going shopping.
And I thought, my god,
there's so much more
to our lives than that.
And so I got the genesis
for my next book, which
was called "Hypocrite in
a Pouffy White Dress."
I wrote all of my
misadventures growing up.
I was raised by urban hippies in
New York City, where I grew up
sort of the one white kid in an
all Puerto Rican neighborhood.
We had to follow a
Maharishi under my parents.
I then chased the Rolling
Stones and dined with them.
And of course all of this led to
my working for the US Congress.
And I put all of these
stories in a book.
And when that became a best
seller, I said, OK, now.
Now I'm going to
write the novel.
I'd actually had an idea,
which was based, again,
on something that I had
lived through myself.
When I was 21 years old
and I got out of college,
a friend of mine and
I in a drunken night
at a pancake house
came up with a plan
that only two drunk
21-year-olds at an IHOP
could come up with, which
was to travel the world based
on the placemat at
the International
House of Pancakes.
And we thought, we're going
to plan this epic trip,
and we're going to start
where nobody we know
has gone before, in the
People's Republic of China.
Now, China at that time--
this was in the late '80s--
would be the
equivalent of deciding
to go to backpack through
North Korea today.
It was a country
that up until then
had really been in lock down.
There were no direct flights.
There were no
direct phone lines.
It was a great mystery
to most people.
But we decided we were young.
We were educated.
How hard could this be?
And we found out.
We arrived in China not
speaking any Mandarin.
We hadn't even looked at a map.
And we found ourselves
quickly over our heads.
We were under government
surveillance most of the time.
Every time we stopped on the
street, they hadn't seen us.
Chinese people had not seen
Westerners tromping through,
and me in an '80s cut-off sweat
shirt with rhinestone earrings.
And we were the freak show.
And so whenever we would just
stoop down to tie our shoe
or to get something
out of our pockets,
we'd get crowds of
people around us.
So we're constantly watched.
And we were hungry,
because unbeknownst to us,
there were not a lot of
restaurants in Communist China
back then.
And if they were, their
menus were all in Chinese,
and they didn't have pictures.
And this is so immensely
naive, but we were surprised.
And so we were hungry, and
we started to fall apart.
I got very sick, physically,
from the pollution
and the stress.
And my friend started to
become mentally unhinged.
It got so bad we almost
did not make it out
of the People's
Republic of China.
And it became sort of
our "Heart of Darkness."
So this is what I had planned.
It was such spectacular
and unbelievable story.
This would be the novel.
This was the book I
was meant to write.
Except there was a problem.
At that time, we had just
gone to-- we being the United
States-- had just gone to war
in Iraq for the second time.
And I overheard our president--
well overheard on television--
saying that the invasion of
Iraq would be a cakewalk.
And I turned to my
husband, and I said,
that sounds like something
stupid I would've
said at 21 in the IHOP,
idea that we could just
go into another country
and it would be easy.
And at the same time,
there were a whole slew
of books that came out
around then about people who,
having a midlife crisis,
went to an ashram in India
or decided to help mend
their broken heart by eating
a lot of pasta in Italy or by
fixing up a house in Tuscany.
There was a general
feeling politically,
socially, culturally
in the United States
that all these other
countries in the world
were really there
for our enrichment,
for our own personal makeover,
or for our national gain.
And I had gone through
a situation where
traveling abroad was
not about conquering.
It was about surrender
and humility.
And so I realized I had to
tell the story of what happened
to me in China as the truth
and talk about what it's
like to be humiliated,
to behave badly and have
bad things happen to you.
And also the unexpected
things and the goodness
of people from many different
cultures who really just
saved us.
And so that became
my third book,
"Undress Me in the
Temple of Heaven."
And it's a true story.
People never think
that it's true.
They think it's a novel.
So then I could turn finally--
finally-- to writing the novel.
"The Ice Cream Queen
of Orchard Street,"
the inspiration for
this was born out
of my being a New Yorker
and obsessed with ice cream.
I am the founder of the
Susan Jane Gilman Institute
of Advanced Gelato Studies.
The research is
extensive, ongoing.
If anybody here wants to
help be a research fellow,
see me afterwards.
I'll hook you up.
As such, I used to love
a local brand here.
It was all along the Northeast.
I don't know who here remembers
it, but it was called Carvel.
And Tom Carvel was the owner,
and he did his own commercials.
And you can probably, I mean
if you're watching YouTube,
google it.
They would have ice cream
cakes, novelty ice cream cakes,
Fudgie the Whale, Cookie Puss.
I'm not making that up.
I don't know who came
up with Cookie Puss.
And he would get on, and
he'd say, "Have a nice Fudgie
the Whale cake for a whale
of a dad on Father's Day."
And he was so gravelly and
these ads were so homespun
that you felt you had
to eat Carvel ice cream
or he might have a heart attack.
So one night I was playing
this for my husband on YouTube,
and I googled Tom Carvel
to read about him.
His name was Tom Carvelas.
He was a Greek immigrant who
arrived in the United States
with nothing.
And slowly he built this
empire of ice cream franchises.
And it struck a chord in me.
I said, that would make a
really interesting story.
Then I read about
Haagen-Dazs, another one
of my personal
favorites, which is
this luxury Scandinavian
brand of ice cream.
It was created by two Jewish
immigrants in the Bronx.
Their parents had
come over from Russia.
They too were poor,
and they wanted
to create a luxury ice cream.
And they created this sort
of fake Danish feel and name
to it because they felt
the Danes had been really
good to the Jews
during the Holocaust.
When I read their story
too, rags to riches,
again I had to write about this.
But there was a problem.
All these real-life ice cream
makers-- Tom Carvel, Rose
and Reuben Mattus, the
founders of Haagen-Dazs--
they were all
genuinely good people.
They had their dreams come true
in America making something
sweet that everybody loved.
They were generous.
They loved children.
They had foundations.
This is not interesting
as a novelist.
I have had an impulse
for a long time
to write a really delicious,
difficult female antihero.
I feel like we haven't
had a lot of them
in modern American
literature, not really
since Scarlett O'Hara.
We've had some psychopaths.
We've had some people start
off bad but wind up good.
But I wanted somebody whose
own bravado and chutzpa
and sheer tenacity, even though
she's difficult and unlikable,
makes her rise.
And then I thought,
oh, what if somebody
who was like Leona
Helmsley or Martha Stewart
created an ice cream empire?
What if somebody like
that-- what if Paul Deen had
a children's kiddie
show on Sunday morning?
What would that look like?
That got interesting.
And so "The Ice Cream Queen
of Orchard Street" was born.
It is the tale of a little
immigrant girl, Malka
Treynovsky, who arrives
in New York City in 1913,
where she's immediately
crippled and abandoned
on the streets of
the Lower East Side.
She's taken in by the man who
accidentally cripples her,
an Italian ices maker,
Salvatore Dinello.
And through her own
tenacity as an orphan,
as somebody who's handicapped,
as a Jew, a female, a child
in the middle of a vast city,
through her own tenacity
and cunning, she rises
over the course of 70 years
to become a woman who President
Eisenhower himself christens
the ice cream queen of America.
She is the doyenne
of an ice cream
empire, along with
her husband, Bert.
She has her own Sunday
morning TV show.
She is a celebrity.
She's a spokeswoman.
She's everybody's
ice cream mama.
She hates kids.
She would rather drink
than eat ice cream.
And she is difficult.
And in the course
of her story, we
hear her rise and
her spectacular fall.
So I'm going to introduce
you a little bit to her.
I will read you
just the beginning
where a book should start,
and you will hear her voice
and who she is.
Just so you know, I record
the audio book of this,
so I've learned to
channel the character.
So you will get to meet
her in the beginning.
"We'd been in America
just three months
when the horse ran over me.
I don't know exactly how
old I was, six perhaps.
When I was born, they
didn't keep records.
All I remember was running down
Hester Street looking for papa.
Overhead, of bleak
sky was flanked
by rooftops, iron fire escapes.
Pigeons circled.
Street peddlers shouted.
Chickens squawked.
There was this strange rickety
calliope of the organ grinder.
Great upheavals of dust
swirled around the push carts,
making the shop signs swing
back and forth like flags.
I heard a clop,
then I was tumbling.
There was a split second
flash of hoof, then
a white hot bolt of
pain, then nothing.
The horse that trampled me
was pulling a penny ices cart.
What a peculiar twist of fate
that turned out to be, no?
If I'd been crippled by, say,
a rag man or a coal vendor,
I would never have
become Lillian Dunkle
as the world knows her today.
Certainly I would never
have become a legend at all.
The public, however,
always assumes
that my fortunes are due
solely to my husband.
Oh, how the media hates its
queens, how it begrudges us.
That horrible photograph the
newspapers keep running now--
the one that makes me look
like Joan Crawford getting
an enema-- is all
the proof you need.
So quick they are to judge.
But let me tell you,
darlings, the Wonder Tundra
with chocolate chips,
rainbow sprinkles,
or chopped peanuts
mixed in to order.
Our signature novelty
cake, the Nilla Rilla,
molded into the shape of our
trademark cartoon monkey,
coated in shaved coconut with
the secret cookie crunch layer
inside.
We'd first marketed it for
birthdays and Father's Day,
but do you realize
how many of you
ordered versions of
this for your weddings?
We did one custom cake
out at a reception
in Syosset that fed 215 people.
It would have made "The
Guinness Book of World Records"
if Bert had remembered
the goddamn camera.
The Tower of Sprinkles, the
Mint Everest, the Fudgie Puppie.
All of these-- all of these--
millions sold every year,
were my concoctions, my ideas.
President Dwight D.
Eisenhower himself once
christened me "The Ice
Cream Queen of America."
I have the signed photograph
of us, in fact, with Mamie,
of course-- all pearls,
bad teeth-- shaking
hands in the Rose Garden.
I'm wearing my first ever
Chanel suit, too, very nearly
the color of
strawberry ice cream.
And this was years before
Jackie Kennedy, thank you.
Today I've no fewer
than three dozen
engraved trophies,
plaques, ribbons,
plus an entire wall of
certificates from the North
Carolina Chamber of Commerce,
the American Dairy Association,
Dow Chemical, even the Institute
of the Maharishi Mahesh
Yogi in Rishikesh, India.
Yogis love ice
cream, apparently.
Who know?
Yet when people hear my
name now, all they think of
are sordid headlines.
A single incident
on live television,
claims of tax evasion
and arrest-- wrongful,
too, need I remind you?
Unfunny jokes on Johnny
Carson, that schlemiel.
You want funny?
Please, I know from funny.
Just yesterday my
grandson informed me
that I'm even an
answer in the latest
edition of Trivial Pursuit.
'Wow, grandma, how
awesome is that?" he said.
Live long enough, I
suppose, you see everything.
But it's a witch hunt.
It was only a local television
station, for God's sake,
and we aired at 7:00 AM
on a Sunday-- a Sunday.
And maybe I had
had a few drinks.
But darlings, you try
hosting a kiddie show
for 13 goddamn years.
But oh, I'm getting
ahead of myself."
And so we meet Lillian Dunkle.
The book begins.
She is 75 years old
and under indictment.
And yet it toggles
back and forth
where she begins to tell us
about her very beginnings
in New York City and her
rise, and then of course we
learn about her fall.
When I started out, this was
just the trajectory I had.
Success, downfall,
and then-- well,
to find out what happens
you have to read it.
But as I started to
research, I began
to learn things about
American history.
Because as I first became
obsessed, of course,
with the ice cream-- this woman
knows everything about it,
where it came from,
the history of it.
And as I learned
more about what ice
cream production was like
in 20th century America,
I saw that it was intimately
tied to the biggest events that
happened in our country.
For example, prohibition
was fantastic for ice cream
production because had all of
these saloon owners and tavern
keepers.
What were they going to
do with their properties?
Not everybody could
make a speakeasy.
And so they turned
all these bars
into ice cream parlors,
which makes sense
because the old fashioned
ice cream parlor sometimes,
they would have the stained
glass lamps in them.
Sometimes they would
have a high bar.
That's because they
probably sold alcohol.
And what people don't realize
is during the Roaring '20s when
you're reading
about bathtub gin,
actually more ice cream was
sold than bootleg liquor.
There were more
ice cream parlors
than there were speakeasies,
so the production really
took off then.
And of course then comes
the Great Depression
and with it also the
repeal of prohibition.
And ice cream production
plummets, so much so
that you started having
bootleg ice cream makers.
And these were
people who would make
ice cream not up to standard.
They would use milk powder
and less milk fat and sugar,
and they'd sell
it under the table
to legitimate producers,
who would pawn it off
as their own product.
So you had this
whole black market
of fake ice cream going on.
And then in World War II,
the United States government
became the largest ice
cream producer in history.
And so I'm going to read one
small little section here,
which shows you how this
impacts Lillian Dunkle's
life, because what happens is
that as an ice cream maker,
she ends up being impacted
by American history
and also affecting it.
Her fate is entwined with
that of our country itself.
And then after this,
I'll take any questions.
"Imagine a single regiment
of beleaguered men landing
on a tiny island in the
middle of the South Pacific.
As they stumble onto an
empty white scythe of beach,
a lone Japanese
warplane rips overhead.
Yet just as quickly
it disappears.
The horizon seems to absorb it.
Slowly, the US soldiers
of the 81st Infantry
realize they are alone.
The Japanese have believed that
the sheer size of the Pacific
will hobble America's
war efforts.
The distances to refuel
are simply too cumbersome.
Yet the islet of Ulithi
is perfectly situated
between Hawaii, Japan,
and the Philippines.
Its volcanic crags barely
poke above the ocean.
And the Japanese
have relinquished it.
Within a single month
of the autumn of 1944,
the United States converts
this blip in the ocean
into the largest secret
Naval base in history.
A port is constructed holding
several hundred vessels.
An airstrip is cleared.
Floating dry docks
are brought in
to repair enormous battleships.
An entire water
distillation plant
is anchored beside a
bakery large enough
to grind out thousands
of loaves of bread, cake,
and pies every day.
The Second World
War, you want to know
about Kristallnacht
and Iwo Jima?
Well, there are books
and movies for that.
Go take yourself to a library.
What I can tell you, darlings,
is that in World War II,
nearly every nation on Earth
stopped producing ice cream.
Sugar was too scarce.
Equipment had to be
redirected to the war effort.
In Italy, Mussolini
banned ice cream simply
because he woke up one morning
and decided it was decadent.
Only the United
States of America
decided ice cream
was an essential item
for troop morale.
And so it alone continued
producing, ordering ice cream
freezers on submarines,
tankers, cargo ships.
Over the course of the war,
the United States military
became the largest ice cream
manufacturer in the world.
And in 1945-- oh-- in
1945, another vessel
pulled into its port of Ulithi.
This was called simply
the ice cream barge.
It was commissioned to
become the world's biggest
floating ice cream parlor.
Made of concrete, it
didn't even have an engine.
It was a refrigerated
Leviathan that
had to be towed
across the Pacific.
And among its crew
of 23 soldiers
was one civilian who'd been
given a special dispensation
from the Army
Corps of Engineers.
He alone was in charge of
overseeing the enormous ice
cream freezer that
churned out 15,000
gallons of ice cream per day.
For the duration of
the war, he alone
toiled inside the
concrete hull ensuring
that the machinery
he helped design
remain in perfect working order.
This man, of course,
was my husband, Bert."
And so there you have it.
You have the story
of Lillian Dunkle.
You have the story of ice cream.
You have the story of the
United States of America.
And this has
become, what started
as a small idea googling an
advertisement for the ice
cream of my childhood and
a beloved gravelly Greek
immigrant who I didn't
even know was such.
And it turned into a 500-page
historic delicious novel.
Thank you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
Questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yes, Ms. Gilman.
You mentioned your other
books were nonfiction.
How different is
the creative process
versus fiction or nonfiction?
SUSAN JANE GILMAN:
Oh, good question.
Writing a novel is harder
by a power of 10 if not 100.
With nonfiction, the challenge
is you've lived the story,
so you know how
it's going to end.
The challenge is,
how do you tell it?
What do you keep in?
What do you leave out?
What can you show and not tell?
With a novel, the
whole story is open,
so you can make things up.
Anything can go any
which way, so it's
a chronic
decision-making process.
What's going to happen
to the character?
How are they going to get
from point A to point B?
If you want to move them from
New York to San Francisco,
do you show them looking
for their car keys?
Do you just start
them off in the car?
Do you put them on the
George Washington Bridge?
Or do you just say, that autumn
we moved to San Francisco?
So when I was writing this
and coming up with the plot,
every single day I was trying
to decide where they should go,
and what they should
do, and how to tell it.
By the time my husband
came home every night,
I was pretty much a mess, and
I couldn't decide anything.
He'd say, do you want
ravioli, or do you
want regular pasta for dinner?
And I don't know.
You decide.
I can't-- I can't-- I can't
make another decision.
And I lived it, and I
breathed it in a certain way
that you don't with
nonfiction because you're
trying to conjure up these
other people in your head.
What I also found, too,
as I was working on it
is that there were times I
could write 60 or 70 pages only
to realize I was writing the
wrong story or the wrong part
of the story.
It was as if I wanted to move my
characters from New York to San
Francisco, and it wasn't
until I got them up to Toronto
I realized that they'd
taken the wrong turn,
and I had to scrap that.
So there were times.
There were several
scenes, chunks, chapters
that I just had to jettison
and start over with.
The same time,
there was something
I just loved about it that's
more fun than nonfiction,
because you get to
explore and create.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Now than you've
written your novel,
did you get it out
of your system?
And what are you
going to write next?
SUSAN JANE GILMAN: Oh, I did
not get it out of my system.
I'm not even sick of ice cream.
I guess I'm going to have
to write another novel.
It's a little addictive in a
very masochistic kind of way,
maybe like mountain climbing.
It's painful.
You say, why am I doing this?
And then as soon as it's done,
you just want to do it again.
I have several ideas
buzzing around in my head,
but I don't know how it is
with people in the room.
But for me, if I'm doing
something creatively,
if I talk about
it, I essentially
sort of lose the
momentum behind it.
So I'll leave you guessing.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Going back to you
talked about your first three
books and this
one as well, there
seems to be a little bit
of an undertone-- sometimes
it's more overt,
sometimes less--
but in feminine development,
a story of powerful women
or women becoming powerful.
I'm curious if you
have encountered--
because it is, as
you've pointed out,
a hefty book-- with young
women today, with young people
today in general we have
these short attention
spans and everybody's
bouncing around.
Have you encountered challenges
with relating to young women?
Have you discovered
certain tricks
to connect more with
young women that
gets your intentions
across to them?
SUSAN JANE GILMAN:
That's a good question.
I think because even though
I would no longer fall
under the rubric of young woman
but I'm perpetually immature,
I don't have trouble
bonding at all.
I can fit right in
with 15-year-olds or 25
or 35-year-olds.
I think women really
respond to other women
when we speak the truth.
We are not sanctimonious.
We have a good sense of humor.
And we just remember
what it was like.
I feel like I'm all
ages at all times.
And there's so much
dreck that is still
being geared towards women.
There's this phrase chick lit,
which is really offensive.
There are all kinds of
genres in literature.
There's YA-- Young Adult.
There's dystopian lit.
There's sci-fi.
There's thriller.
There's crime.
Only the phrase chick lit
carries this really negative
connotation, the
idea being that it's
by young women for young
women, and therefore it's
stupid and brainless
and it's touchy-feely
and about emotions.
And that's not to say that
there aren't books like that
out there, but it's used
to sort of tar anything
by women or with women
who might be included
or even part of the audience.
And I find that
makes it much harder.
And I think my fellow writers,
older and younger than me,
find that is just
being given legitimacy
if you're writing
from a point of view
of your half of the species.
And readers, I get a
lot of email from men.
"I didn't think I would like
your book," they start out.
"My wife was reading your
book next to me in bed
and laughing." "My girlfriend
gave me your book."
"I saw that my girlfriends
were passing around your book
and wondered what this was.
And I read it, and it was really
funny, and it was really good,
and I got a lot out of it."
And there's this surprise.
So that's what I
get from the men.
And from the women I
get, "You understand me.
I can't believe it."
I got one, "I'm a 16-year-old
gay woman out in Oklahoma,
and when I read
'Kiss My Tiara' I
felt like I wasn't alone
for the first time.
Or, "My friends
and I backpacked.
We went backpacking, and
I felt so freaked out
that something was
wrong with me because I
wasn't having a good time.
I loved 'Undress Me in
the Temple of Heaven.'"
When you speak to a truth
that is not about girly stuff
and about hair and makeup and
diet and being decorative,
I think women respond to that.
We're hungry for
it, because so much
of what is geared towards us,
whether we're seven or 70,
it's pink purple sparkles.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Since we are here
at, like you said, Google,
how have you seen technology
change book reading
habits or book selling habits?
SUSAN JANE GILMAN: Oh,
e-books, e-books, e-books.
It's changed the
industry, obviously,
because people can-- I'll
tell people about a book,
and they'll say, hang on.
And they'll get on
their technology,
and they'll download
it instantly.
And for a writer in a certain
way, that's kind of great.
I get a lot of, oh,
where's your book?
Oh, I'll go pick it
up at the library.
And there they buy
it in front of you.
That's kind of cool.
The problem is then
you can't see people
reading it in front of you.
There's something really nice.
You know, I was on the
Amtrak, and I look up,
and somebody's like this.
For a writer, that
makes your heart sing.
It's like, oh my god.
And so the technology
has made it harder
for your book to be anything
but digits, but binary code.
And that's a little
unnerving if you're a writer.
Certainly now all of us
writers, I'm on Facebook.
I'm on Twitter.
I'm on Instagram.
I have a blog.
I don't have time for
Tumblr because I'm actually
going to try to
write another book.
But it does diffuse our own
attention and our own writing.
And then there's
everything that's
going on right now
with publishers,
with the pricing of
e-books, with Amazon.
And that's a whole other
mess, which is, in my mind,
threatening writers.
Because there is
talk about doing away
with traditional
publishing houses.
And I will say this
since I have a forum.
I read something
yesterday about how
if Amazon does away with
traditional publishers,
it's a good thing.
Writers don't need editors.
All you need is a good spell
check program and an editing
program, and you
can do it yourself.
So I would like to say this.
My editors are not middlemen,
and my editors cannot be
replaced by a program.
Anybody who's an athlete
who's had a great coach or who
is a musician who has a great
teacher or a great producer
knows that you need somebody
if you are a creative person
or if you have a talent
to help you be better.
All the editors I've had
have been really spectacular.
They have vision.
They hand hold.
They deal with us writers.
We're a little mercurial.
They keep us on track.
They help us become better.
They push us, and they
make our products better.
I don't want to
work in a day where
I don't have a publishing house.
Plus there's not
just spell checking.
There is figuring out where
a book fits into the world.
Are you just writing something
that's been out there already?
There's institutional memory.
There is copy editing.
There's fact checking.
There's legal vetting.
There's book design.
These are important things.
And the writers I know
who are self-publishing
in this world taking advantage
of all the electronica
are finding they still
want a really good editor.
They want a sounding board.
They need a copy editor.
They need a proofreader.
They need somebody to help
them check their facts.
They want a designer.
They want it to look good.
Except because they're
self-publishing
using the technology,
they have to pay
for this all out of
pocket themselves.
So what the world could look
like is that unless you have
enough money to fully subsidize
your own virtual publishing
house, the work
that comes out there
is going to be either
shoddy and/or just written
by people of means.
So I see technology on
one hand putting books
into so many more hands
in a much faster way
and giving me as an author
a lot of ways including
this to interact with
people, which is great.
Because usually we authors,
it's not glamorous.
You sit alone in a room
three, four, five years.
That's the writing process.
Nobody's doing a reality
show about authors
where we're given an assignment.
We write a book each
week, and then we're
eliminated based on who is the
best book and who is the worst.
It's just this boring,
very limited process.
So to have social media, great.
But the idea that
technology could
replace publishers and editors,
or even just a nice hardcover
book to hold in your hand or
bop somebody over the head
with, that I'm going to miss.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little bit
about how you came up
with the idea for Lillian
Dunkle the character?
How do you keep a character
that you've made up,
how do you make that
character authentic as opposed
to a caricature?
SUSAN JANE GILMAN: Oh, how do
you make a character authentic?
You just keep digging.
Anything that when
I write a character
that comes a little too easily
or that sounds like somebody
I've heard before,
then I have to check it
for being, for lack of
a better word, shtick.
And the more you immerse
yourself in the world,
you think about things.
And it's kind of
an acting exercise.
I took some theater classes
when I was really young,
like in junior high
school, and I still
call upon that to
get into their heads.
As a writer, I think I'm every
character in the book here.
I'm Spreckels the
Clown, which is
played by a closeted gay man
named Harvey Valentine, who
shows up in the '50s.
I'm her 19-year-old
grandson Jason,
I'm her dyslexic husband Bert.
I am the Dinellos,
the immigrants
who come and bring her in.
At some point, you have
to get into their head
and imagine, how
is it going to be?
And what would life be like?
And how would people see things?
You're constantly shape
shifting as a writer.
And I think all
of us I can speak
are on the lookout for cliche,
for keeping something alive.
And there are also skills
you learn as a writer.
I went to an MFA
program, and there
tends to be an idea
that we writers,
we're hit with a
bolt of inspiration
and it just pours out of us.
But there are tools to writing
like there are to playing music
or playing a sport.
You learn how to show, not tell.
You learn how to write a
three-dimensional character.
You learn how using a
different point of view
will create a different tone.
There's just practical stuff.
And the more you do it, one
hopes the better you become.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about choosing
to write a historical novel.
Because when you're coming from
an all nonfiction background,
that's all very present.
You were saying all
of your books come out
of immediacy of your experience.
And so I'm wondering
if you had set out
to write a historical
novel or if that was just
the story that
presented itself to you.
And then also if you think that
that sort of structure of facts
that come from the
history you're placing
your story within helped you
structure your first fiction
work.
SUSAN JANE GILMAN:
Yeah, I didn't
realize that this was
going to be so historical.
And you're right.
Most of my work has
been very reactive.
I have to respond to something
that's pissing me off
in the culture with
an entire book.
This was the first one that
was more of a Valentine
that came of love.
But I think I was responding
too to the lack of these really
complicated, yummy, awful,
wonderful antiheroes.
I wanted to do a female,
so there was some of that.
This book grew.
I mean, I was
joking about calling
it "The Moby Dick of
Ice Cream" at one point
because I had so much
about the history of ice
cream and the chemistry.
And it really
revealed itself to me
as I did the research to
find how much ice cream
history happened
in the 20th century
and how it became integrated
into my characters' experience.
So the book sort of
mushroomed and became
more-- the history itself
became integral to her story.
As opposed to I first envisioned
it as just a backdrop,
like, oh, old New York.
That would be really cool.
Nobody's written
about that before.
But I thought I would do it
a new way, and there we go.
AUDIENCE: Do you think you
would revisit historical?
SUSAN JANE GILMAN: I think so.
Probably I would not go back
to the immigrant story again.
We're not going to have a
"Liver Queen of Ludlow Street."
But a few of the ideas
I have floating around,
you hear about these little
nuggets or things that
happened in history, and you
go, nobody told me about that.
Oh my gosh.
Ooh.
And then you want to
pull at the thread
and see what it leads to.
It's fun.
It's archaeology.
I like the research.
I worked as a journalist
for a few years
before I went into
writing books.
And there is that
part of me that
just loves to dig and uncover.
I guess I have a feeling
we're pretty much out of time.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you for listening to
the story of Lillian Dunkle
and "The Ice Cream Queen
of Orchard Street."
If anybody has questions
for me afterwards,
you can always email me.
My website is
susanjanegilman.com.
I am on Facebook as-- wait
for it-- Susan Jane Gilman.
I am on Twitter, SusanJGilman.
I am on Instagram something or
other, SusanJGillman2, I think,
SJGilman.
I'm all over the media.
Come visit me.
Talk to me.
I'd love to see you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]